okay so I want to talk about expanding
the chemistry functionality in
Mathematica and I kind of want to just
give some motivation for this initially
so would tell you where I'm coming from
I got a PhD in theoretical physical
chemistry and when I joined when I
started graduate school I had no
programming experience whatsoever they
just take you in based on your math test
scores and immediately I was a TA in a
physical chemistry lab and it was
introduced to Mathematica and I did all
my simulations all my work in
Mathematica and so I've really felt like
more people ought to be able to do
chemistry in Mathematica just the
ability to I mean everybody here knows
the ability to to experiment in the
notebook interface to get a hands-on
feel for things can really can really
really help students to to learn and so
so I think that uh expanding what what
Mathematica does in chemistry is
worthwhile goal so first we take a look
at what what has been available in the
Wolfram language so we've always had
import/export you can import PDB
structures you can and this is it this
gives you a nice 3d ribbon diagram let's
see I thought it was three and then yeah
there we go and you can also import mo L
files or XYZ files and you can
essentially look at a static image or a
3d image you can get a few properties
you can get the the vertex types the the
edge rules these are these things that
have graph names but essentially they're
not computable documents there let's see
we don't need you they're not computable
objects they're they're they're static
you can't change them so next we have
chemical data which was introduced in
version 6 and chemical data allows you
to query for properties of
the thousands of chemicals in the
knowledgebase we have the this data has
been curated from sources such as NIST
or pubchem or chemspider and it's got
lots of experimentally experimental
properties so I can ask for the
combustion heat of propane I can ask for
Henry's law constant isobaric heat
capacity at a particular temperature
using thermodynamic data and so that so
chemical data has been around for a
while and it was a vastly expanded in
version 10 so next we have entity value
which came online much later adding a
little bit more capability so we can we
we can ask for properties of a group of
molecules and we can make a data set of
it and it's very nice but it's still
it's still static it still depends upon
curators having having found the data
and brought it to you next we have the
Wolfram data repository I put a few
entity stores in the novel from data
repository the the GDB 9 database this
is a database of over 133,000 chemicals
and so you can download that by
prepending this to this resource data
object to your entity stores you can
query for a random entity it has various
properties including experimental but
also calculated properties you can look
at the the data and a data set and so
again it's it's a it's it's static you
can't change the entities and so there
are a few more of these that I would
highly recommend checking those out and
then finally there's Wolfram Alpha where
you can ask natural language input like
how many carbon atoms in 5.4 six
kilograms of propane and I recently
hooked that one up myself
you could ask how many what's the pH of
two molar acetic acid you who can ask
questions that lead to a step-by-step
answer you can ask for the let's see you
can do your stoichiometry homework 0.2
molar methane plus oxygen goes to 7
milliliters water plus co2 it'll balance
the reaction for you and you can get you
can do step by step let's see that's
dynamic so we will go to the cached
version and so we can walk you through
step by step how to solve these types of
problems and so that's the capabilities
for chemistry in the Wolfram language so
far but there has always been a demand
for more so here I'm looking at a bunch
of questions that were asked on the
stack exchange so people people talk
about the fact that there's no
stereochemistry information in the in
chemical data how the fact that you
can't the functions use to visualize
things aren't aren't exposed to the user
so their options aren't are known
there's no documentation so people ask
how could I add a legend to one of these
plots how could I access the internal
function that plots the molecules
specifically they want to change the
colors they want to plot random DNA
strings let's see they want to fake a
molecule plot when we don't have the
information some people have gone
through and even made molecular orbital
visualizations and Wolfram language yeah
I I I asked like at least three of these
questions to be honest this was that was
before I had access to the source code
and very recently this happened actually
only just a few months ago while I was
still working on what I'm gonna show you
today a user who's actually I think he's
listed as a consultant for the company
he came up with a molecule fewer package
and so this addresses the fact that in
the standard chemical data you don't
have any double bonds and you can't do a
highlighting and so but it's again it's
fairly static it it you have to import
mo L files or or to retrieve information
from chemical data or pet pubchem and so
I'm interested in introducing a wolf and
language molecule data structure so who
would be interested in having a
computable data object yeah
me and Bob definitely I suspect I don't
know about Bob but I suspect we both
kind of joined the company with the
express purpose of getting to this
position so that we could introduce this
this package the fact that we also
needed jobs at the time probably was
serendipity okay so I think the target
audience at first might be chemistry
students and educators constructing a
molecule and manipulating it changing
out a carbon for a hydrogen changing a
changing an oxygen carbonyl protonating
a anise
an acetic acid and could be gives a real
hands-on feel and so I feel like that
could be very helpful to just students
and then researchers are in grad
students are mainly when I was a grad
student I wanted it so that's what I'm
thinking of computational chemists good
day and Kim Kim informatics or molecular
modeling these are the the people we
think might be interested in having a
computable chemical object what form
would it take it would be similar to a
graph because like a graph it has the
atoms or vertices the bonds or edges we
could even we can do we can use the
graph capabilities in Mathematica to to
do computations although it's a it's
kind of roundabout so we can make a
graph here out of benzophenone it looks
fairly from a chemical standpoint it
doesn't look very good but we could grab
information from chemical data and and
make the layout of the graph look better
you could even ask chemical data
specifically for a structure graph and
this gives you a graph so this is a
computable object you can change its
highlighting but more specifically you
use functions like fighting shortest
paths to find the longest shortest path
in this molecule would be from this
hydrogen to this and it loops on around
and so so in some ways graph thus two
people are already using the graph
capabilities to to do count and chemical
computations but there's a lot of
differences that are not covered by the
graph so the vertices are not distinct
in a graph duplicate vertices are pruned
let's say vertex and edge properties
like charge isotope bond order we can
add those to a graph but they don't they
don't take a they're not taken into
account in graph computations whereas in
chemistry they're very very important
and then hyper edges this is a
relationship between more than two two
vertices so it's not an edge it's a
hyper edge so that here I'm specifically
talking about stereo elements where you
have three four or five atoms with a
specific 3d spatial relationship so so
that's what it might look like what
might you call it the thought is to call
it a molecule you could say hey that
that doesn't work because the IU pack
defines a molecule as something that is
connected there can't be any any
disconnected pieces and it can't have a
charge which is a little bit too
restricted for us if you go to the IU
pack you can find they have a molecule
molecular entity which is any
constitutionally or isotopically
distinct to add a molecule ion ion pair
radical
so that pretty much covers it but it
would be far too confusing to call
something in maliki molecular entity in
the Wolfram language another very
precise definite our name would be an
atom container which is what's used by
the cdk toolkit because it that's
literally what it is it just houses a
bunch of atoms but it just doesn't have
the right ring so for now we'll use
molecule
what would the input form for a molecule
do so you have to you have to it at
least give it the atoms and
bonnes you could give it there are other
things you can give it you can give it
properties you can give it stereo
elements but at the very least you have
to give it atoms and bonds so we could
do that we could create a molecule right
here with three carbon atoms and two
bonds and then we could query having
just created this we could query the
knowledge base to find any any chemical
data entities that match that and we
find that we have propane in there at
least six times with different isotopic
substitutions we can we can set the the
properties for we can for any atoms here
using the property head this is what we
do in graph so here we sang the the
formal charge of the middle carbon atom
is one so we put a carbo-cation and we
create this we can look at it yes sure
enough there's a positive charge right
there notice notice that the hydrogen's
were added by default by valence it's
okay and so if we wanted to look at the
input form of the molecule after we
created it we see that the properties
have been moved to the end and an
association it's a very convenient
method for storing molecule you can
create a molecule from an entity take
one of those deuterated propane's
and create a molecule and then we can
look at the input form of it and we see
that the mass number property for for
all of the hydrogen's has been set to
two and we and it's got vertex
coordinates because those were available
in the in the the chemical data packet
pretty 4i yes so it's in its in general
utilities so it's not it's in a packet
it it is yeah it's it's there it's ever
it's on everybody's a Wolfram language
distribution but it's not it's not
expressly documented but I really feel
like everybody should use it because
it's fantastic it really a lazy eye I
like I like to be risky and use
undocumented functions okay so you could
create a molecule from an entity you
could create a molecule from any any
name right so we can we can store a list
of names in a persistent object loaded
in and then just find any random
chemical name from that list and create
a molecule from it there we go
we just created 2h midazolam
we can look at the input form of it we
can look at the molecule plot of it okay
and then we can search the knowledge
base to see if we have such a such an
entity ah so we don't apparently we
might have the the hydrogen at a
different position but would when the
last time I use random I got I got one
and found one okay you can also use a
smile string which is a very compact
form of writing out the the grant of the
chemical graph so again I have a
persistent object here I grab a random
smile string and create an object from
it
[Music]
and when we plot it
and so to read this it's we started at
oxygen let's see let's make that a
little bit bigger to read a smile string
you read it from left to right let's
find out which so this was the ferry
first oxygen it's connected to a carbon
as we see in the string that carbon is
double bonded to an oxygen but it's also
then bonded to this ring structure it's
bonded to this aromatic carbon which is
part of a ring and the rings are denoted
by these by the integer digits I highly
recommend going and looking at smile
strings it's going to be the easiest way
to to enter in a molecule I mean what I
love about that about that so say we
take this take that smile string and now
we make a new molecule but we edit it so
let's say on some random carbon here I'm
just going to put a bunch of a put a big
long hydrocarbon chain on it it's that
easy that's why people for storing large
amounts of molecules where you don't
have any property know anything about
them other than their structure the
smile string is the the preferred
serialization format okay so so now you
might ask about visualization let's
again take a look at what we've done so
far if we look at a ATP you can look at
the molecule plot or the color structure
diagram note that the color structure
diagram shows no stereochemistry
information and the the 3d plot has no
double bonds which is something I've
heard complaints about from from users
so we introduced an entity value the
multi bond molecule plot earlier in the
year or last year but we still don't
have stereochemistry information there
because it's not in the Pacolet so but
that could be solved with our with the
new package so if we create a create two
at two molecules here using them their
name their chemical names we can make
adenosine adenosine triphosphate
we can look at a molecule one there we
go you see the stereochemistry is
indicated we can ask whether M 1 is a
stub structure of M 2 we find that it is
but if we ask the other way around we
would
right right okay
right okay all right I swear I was just
hit Apple see so we could ask if m2 was
a sub structure of m1 no it's not and
then we could actually find the
substructure find the adenosine in the
adenosine triphosphate and highlight it
so that's neat
we could create a molecule out of a
fullerene we could month we can plot it
and we could ask to highlight only the
five membered rings that's what this is
this is a smart string it's like a smile
string but it allows patterns so what
this says is it's a five membered ring
carbon atoms and this ampersand stands
for or now that's a whatever they at
symbol is stands for any kind of ring
bond but here we're saying there are
five bonded within a ring so this only
highlights the five membered rings and
then also we can look so this I think
will be useful for for teaching so so
you can make a molecule out of l-alanine
and you see that it does have
stereochemistry information so we plot
it labeling the indices you can look at
the inside and see that it's got a
clockwise rotation what this means is
that cart atom number two this carbon is
chiral and the ligands around it are one
three four and nine and that if you look
down the bond from atom one to Adam two
you'll find out it was three four and
nine to be in a clockwise direction it's
a little bit confusing but we could look
at we could change that and just make a
make it counterclockwise and let's see
did I enter this in right so then you
can do a molecule plot of them and stare
down the axis of that bond if you look
from here you find blue or green blue
purple and a counterclockwise direction
whereas here it's green blue a purple
in a clockwise direction and so that can
give a hands-on feeling for what we mean
by stereochemistry when we teach it
let's see we could do we could skip this
because we're running out of time well
let's see just just show you can you can
query for Q si q SI are properties
quantitative structure-activity
relationship which is essentially
querying for a large number of of
numeric property values and then these
are used in machine learning
applications to predict molecular
properties or biological activity
another method for predicting properties
based on structure from the 1980s was
the Joe back method which is hooked up
in an alpha right now where you could
decompose a molecule into all these
different sub structures and add up the
contributions for each of these to try
and come up with an estimate for the
melting point enthalpy heat of fusion
and whatnot it's it's not the best
estimation method but it's very easy to
implement okay we could do a fingerprint
similarity searching we've got hooked up
a wide variety of of different types of
fingerprints and what we could do so
here we we read in I'm not going to do
this right now it takes about 17 seconds
to read in these 10,000 molecules we
create a molecule nearest function from
that and then we can query that for the
molecules that are most similar to a
random choice a random molecule so
here's our random molecule and then we
query the nearest function for the five
molecules in this set that were most
similar and then you can visualize the
results
did you do
Oh
okay um so I should probably have read
that in differently okay so we can do we
can do fingerprint similarity searching
we can do 3d structure manipulation so
we had we take a molecule from this long
smile string and we can manipulate it
yeah we'll make things a little bit
larger we can query for bond lengths
bond angles let's look at this carbon
hydrogen bond length its 1.09 angstroms
we could try and make that larger or
smaller and you can watch the the force
field energy increase wildly you can
minimize it back to its original state
you could theoretically do a constrained
minimization select this atom and this
atom and say I'd like them right now
there are 12 angstroms apart I'd like
you to find a geometry where they're
only 6 angstrom apart when seeing we
constrain it and this is where we got
and so you found the molecule there are
enough rotatable bonds where I was able
to find a conformation where those were
only six angstroms apart notice the
energy was 223 kilocalories per mole if
we remove that constraint and then
minimize again we can find a much lower
energy
you